[Música]
[Aplausos]
es usual que la gente me pregunte usted
la muchacha de las cartas y aunque no me
gustan las etiquetas desde hace seis
años con orgullo
respondo si esta soy yo desde niña
pequeñita pero matona diría mi mamá
entendí el camino al éxito estudiar en
la universidad o buscar un trabajo sin
demasiados contratiempos mi vida mi
historia y mi contexto han sido
sencillos me encaminé hacer alguien
barrios desamparados nació pedro él
también soñaba con ser alguien pero su
vida y su contexto fueron muchísimo más
complicados hambre pobreza abandono y
como si fuera el personaje de una
película de terror su final fue la
cárcel
una sentencia demasiado larga para un
joven que apenas empezaba a vivir
marta nació en guapi les secas yo
demasiado joven siendo casi una niña y
tuvo tres hijos en medio de una relación
violenta y la obligación de mantener a
tres niños algún buen samaritano le
ofreció introducir drogas a un centro
penal en su vagina a cambio de 50 mil
colones ustedes se imaginan a cuánto
equivale a 50 mil colones cuando se
tiene hambre
marta no es la reina del sur' pero fue
tendencia como la peor de las
narcotraficantes
julio julio nació en ciudad neily pero
vivió toda su vida en alajuela y julia
tenía la vida perfecta el trabajo
perfecto la familia perfecta pero una
combinación de ira con el abuso de licor
le llevaron a la cárcel
su vida perfecta se desplomó en un
segundo le podría pasar a cualquiera
verdad
para ti patinazo en nicaragua y siendo
una niña su mamá la regaló y luego la
vendieron a un hombre 23 años mayor que
la agredió y la prostitución
su final es demasiado triste como para
verbalizar pero al igual que los otros
siendo una niña terminó en la cárcel
mi destino el de para ti pedro julio y
marta eran como líneas paralelas no
estaban destinados a juntarse porque nos
dividía un contexto enorme pero siendo
estudiante de derecho como si no fuera
una verdad muy obvia entendí que las
carteles reproducen la exclusión y la
falta de oportunidad de la sociedad
misma y que solo un lugar oscuro y feo
maloliente donde ponemos a las personas
y ponemos a los otros para que se nos
olvide que existen siendo estudiante de
derecho con mucha ingenuidad y mucho
corazón los mejores amigos cómplices que
alguien pueda tener inició un proyecto y
con la plena convicción de que yo sabía
lo que estaba haciendo acuérdese de mi
mamá pequeñita pero matona spoiler no
tenía la menor idea de lo que estaba
haciendo en este proyecto
teníamos la intención o tenemos la
intención de dar herramientas de
empoderamiento socio laboral a personas
privadas de libertad para que puedan
iniciar sus propias ideas de negocio y
sus propios modelos de negocio haciendo
y sumando otros centros penales inicie
un proyecto de empoderamiento juvenil en
la cárcel de menores y posteriormente en
la cárcel de mujeres y acá
acá es donde el destino hace su magia
pedro como participante del proyecto de
empoderamiento juvenil se encargó todos
los días te hace ver lo mal que lo
estaba haciendo
como mis ideas no tenían sentido y no se
adaptaban a su realidad
usted a usted se le olvida que a las
cuatro de la tarde este portón se cierra
y usted se va pero yo me quedo aquí
pero no se acuerda verme dicho esa frase
pero todavía hoy me resuena todos los
días en mi cabeza
[Música]
bueno para ti
era un participante del mismo proyecto
su utilidad la caracteriza y la tristeza
en sus ojos como era cualquiera
marta marta de la energía canalizada en
una sola persona de verdad yo no sé cómo
canaliza tanta energía era participante
del proyecto de empoderamiento femenino
y toda la semana me interpelaba la hora
pero para cuando es que esto tiene que
ser para más este que está haciendo para
que ésta sea para todo mundo es que mis
compañeras en el módulo quieren venir
y julio
julio de 2000 gran inspiración
inspiración es el conejillo de indias de
la primera generación es con quién
cometí todos los errores posibles
un día le dije mi sueño es que esto sea
para más privados de libertad su sueño
hace posible el mío me dijo
mi destino el de julio
y el de todas estas personas no está
destinado a cumplirse pero insisto a
unirse pero sí sí yo yo creo en el
destino
volvamos a pedro
pedro siempre me ha hecho las preguntas
más difíciles es el mejor estudiante que
he tenido en mi vida un día me pregunto
lado que es el empoderamiento y es ahora
para qué sirve en este caso usted y está
de quién soy yo otro día me dijo
calladito lado usted cree que alguien
como yo pueda ir a la universidad y esta
pregunta yo si sabía cómo responderla y
le dije sí y lo vamos a hacer
pero ese año no sólo ganó el
bachillerato y el examen de admisión
sino que de nuevo jugando con el destino
logró salir de la cárcel a tiempo para
incorporarse a la universidad y ser lo
que siempre ha sido el mejor estudiante
la universidad no está siendo fácil pero
ustedes creen que este muchacho se rinde
en los últimos días se ha incorporado a
un proyecto de acción social de la
universidad en la que ayuda a otros
jóvenes indígenas a incorporarse a la
universidad y poder acceder a una beca
la última vez que almorzamos me dijo la
uia yo entendí que es el poder eso es
poder soñar y es cierto eso es lo que
nos hace humanos
marta se incorporó recientemente con su
familia volvió con sus hijos y no le
está haciendo nada sencillo empezó su
emprendimiento y obvio me sigue
interpelando para cuando lauren para
cuando mis compañeros necesitan ir esto
tiene que ser para todas
para
patti se encuentra en sociedad de hace
pocos meses y para para ti no está
haciendo nada fácil es como si una
fuerza
se encaminará hacia las gracias en línea
recta pero una fuerza sobrehumana las
estuviera en el camino contrario
para ti a la persona más resiliente que
conozco con la mitad de lo que ha pasado
la mitad de nosotros ni siquiera nos
levantaríamos pero ella sigue luchando y
va a seguir
julio
el hoy de julio a mí no me sorprende
es un microempresario exitoso tiene tres
emprendimientos julio está perdiendo su
sueño y si de paso está cumpliendo el
mío
en los últimos seis años he conocido
muchas personas como para ti pero julio
marta
sus nombres son ficticios pero sus
historias no lo son
más de 15.000 personas se encuentran
privadas de libertad con un 52 por
ciento de hacinamiento personas como
pedro duermen en un baño con un ojo
abierto nuestras cárceles tienen el 52
por ciento más de la población para las
que fueron construidas el 70 como 29 por
ciento de estas personas están
sentenciadas por delitos menores
personas como marta que están recluidas
por microtráfico de drogas o hurtos ros
nada lo que nos venden las novelas
58 de estas personas son personas
menores de 35 años
algunas tan jóvenes como patti que
alcanzaron la mayoría de edad tras las
venas
15 mil personas aprendiendo en libertad
15 mil personas aprendiendo a vivir en
libertad desde el tierra
y a mí no me deja de resonar la pregunta
de como dos destinos pueden ser tan
distintos únicamente por el lugar en el
que nacimos y las oportunidades que el
azar nos dio
a mí no me deja de razonar la pregunta
de qué hubiera sucedido si alguna de
estas personas hubiera tenido las
oportunidades que yo tuve y qué tan
probable hubiera podido ser que
estuviéramos en lugares distintos
cuando en las noticias con morbo les
llaman golondrinas de corazón yo deseara
que lo fueran porque una golondrina no
hace verano pero a estas personas lo que
les hemos negado toda la vida son alas
las posibilidades de soñar y las
posibilidades de volar
mi sueño es una sociedad inclusiva mi
sueño es que el destino y en estas
personas se junten pero con igualdad de
oportunidades una sociedad en la que
nadie se quede atrás
cuál es el sueño yo le te invito a creer
en el destino yo les invito a dejarte
sorprender y les invito a coincidir con
quien menos lo esperamos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]